good news horror fans 2018 is shaping up
to be a banner year for spooky and
spine-tingling video games from ground
breaking zombie shooters to vampire RPGs
there's something for every fright fan
in the new year
here's a look at some of the most
promising and chilling titles so far
over kills our Walking Dead like The
Walking Dead zombie hordes over kills
our Walking Dead is proving very very
hard to put down for good first
announced in 2014 with a message from
Walking Dead creator Robert Kirkman the
first-person survival shooter from the
studio behind the payday series was
originally scheduled for a 2016 release
now it looks like The Walking Dead will
finally shamble onto Xbox one
Playstation 4 and PC in the second half
of 2018 fingers crossed because
Overkill's The Walking Dead promises not
to be you're one of the mills Amba
shooter it challenges players to survive
the zombie ridden wasteland using a
combination of action stealth and
resource management and like Rick Grimes
and his followers you won't be going it
alone either while you can play solo
cooperative multiplayer will be the main
focus
state of decay to need more zombie
action in the new year state of decay
too is sure to please Walking Dead fans
especially those that enjoy the
survivalist aspects more than the gore
like the first game in the series state
of decay 2/4 goes active zombie hunting
and asks you to stay put hunker down and
build a base that can protect you and
your followers from the undead horde
that's easier said than done and every
choice you make us lasting consequences
you'll need seeds and equipment to grow
a garden and feed your crew for example
which means leading excursions into town
to secure supplies which means facing
swarms of zombies maybe you should focus
on building a guard tower instead it's
up to you that kind of variation is what
makes state of decay 2 so compelling
you'll never play the same game twice
look for this Xbox one and Windows 10
exclusive in spring of 2018 Metro Exodus
the Metro franchise doesn't have the
name recognition of games like dead
space or Bioshock for 2018 s Metro
Exodus available on Xbox one Playstation
4 and PC might change that in a
post-apocalyptic world where nuclear
fallout is forced humanity to retreat to
underground subway tunnels to survive
players fight their way out of a mutant
filled Moscow and cross the continent in
search of a better future like the
previous two games in the series players
still need to engage in meticulous
stealth based challenges and fast-paced
combat to survive and gathering vital
supplies are still a big part of the
experience but Exodus shakes things up
by combining linear levels with new open
areas for players to explore
blood-stained ritual of the night if you
miss those traditional 2d Castlevania
games Konami used to crank out at a
regular clip longtime Castlevania
producer koji Igarashi has you covered
his blood-stained a ritual of the night
isn't an official Castlevania game but
it might as well be like Castlevania
blood-stained stars occurs protagonist
who explores a spooky Castle filled with
demons and secrets you'll amass a wide
array of weapons and face all kinds of
monstrous foes in your journey while
robust RPG like leveling and crafting
systems will ensure that blood-stained
that never gets old and yes while
blood-stained is a Kickstarter backed
game which have disappointed in the past
don't let that turn you off Igarashi and
his crew say they purposefully delayed
the cross-platform crowdfunded title
until 2018 in order to make sure blood
stain the ritual of the night lives up
to its potential code vein mix Dark
Souls with the vampires and what do you
get okay well blood-borne throw in some
anime inspired art however and you end
up with code vain an upcoming horror
action title from Bandai Namco available
on Xbox one Playstation 4 and PC code
vain words as influences on its sleeve
producers aren't shy about evoking the
souls comparison and why should they be
Dark Souls combat is just a thrilling as
it is difficult and you'd be
hard-pressed to find a better model for
an action RPG but code vain isn't just a
knockoff and that's where the vampire
elements come in players can suck their
enemy's blood and then use a
supercharged fluid to unleash special
attacks buff their character stats and
access all kinds of other supernatural
powers days gone if you've ever watched
Sons of Anarchy and thought to be better
with monsters then days gone is for you
the upcoming PlayStation 4 exclusive a
details the adventures of a biker gang
turn survivalist group in the Pacific
Northwest and an open-world adventure
that takes cues from tomb raider ground
a Theft Auto and the Last of Us as
deikun's st. John
first a decimated Pacific Northwest's
varied terrain on foot and by motorcycle
attacking enemy outposts while making
sure your gang remains on top the
monsters will make that difficult set
two years after a plague ravaged the
earth and killed most of humanity the
world of days gone is filled with zombie
like creatures called fricos freakazoid
your typical and dead foes either they
don't just shamble or shuffle sometimes
they run and they're really fast in
addition to many human enemies Saint
John will need to outmaneuver and
dispatch swarms of hundreds of fricos
all while making sure he's got the
resources he needs to fight another day
while the specifics of days gone story
remain elusive the technology on display
in the demos alone is undeniably
impressive making this one of the most
anticipated titles of the first half of
2018 plus it's likely the only game of
the year to feature a weaponized a
grizzly bear its backup ices flower
don't make it
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]